teenaged members of the Los Angeles
Police Department cadet program are in
hot water for apparently taking their
work home with them they were arrested
for allegedly stealing three police
cruisers Jamie yuccas has a story a pair
of high-speed pursuits ended with two
stolen black-and-white police cruisers
crashed on the streets of Los Angeles
Wednesday night the vehicles were driven
by boys ages 15 and 17
officers were surprised to discover that
teenagers were part of the Los Angeles
Police Department's cadet program it
appears at this point that they accessed
our inventory system logged in under a
sergeants name who they knew that was on
vacation and impersonated him to to
cover their use of the vehicles
shortly after their arrest one of the
teenagers confessed that a third squad
car had been stolen police found it
parked near a precinct and arrested a 16
year old female we do daily inventories
of equipment you know it obviously
didn't work in this case we believe that
the LAPD cadet program has a tremendous
impact on the lives of our youth
recruitment video for the cadet Academy
shows a leadership program for 13 to 20
year olds providing life skills and
character development we're focused on
creating successful young adults to go
out there and be productive citizens
which ultimately is going to
about 2300 teens are enrolled in the
program Police Chief Charlie Beck has
called for a full review also recovered
were two tasers and a bulletproof vest
the investigation continues to determine
just when the police property went
missing for CBS this morning Saturday
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles here's the
thing if you're police cadet maybe don't
go joyriding with a police vehicle you
think that was fairly obvious is that
Ana Manuel one would think it is a one
would think